يرتدي رئيس الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين ثياب
الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وهو يحدث طفلا
روسيا بالهاتف ويضع جانبا لغه الوعيد
والتهديد بوتين امر قوته بوقف لاطلاق
النار في اوكرانيا لمده 36 ساعه تبدا من
الساعه 12 يوم السادس يناير ليحتفل كثير
من المسيحيين من الارثوذكس بعيد الميلاد
بما فيهم اولئك الذين يعيشون في روسيا
واوكرانيا هذه الخطوه التي رفضتها
اوكرانيا واعتبرتها نفاقا جاءت بعد مناشده
من راس الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
قررونيات كذلك في سياق مشاعل وساطه
التركيه التي يقودها الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بعد مكالمتين مع الرئيس الاوكراني
والرئيس الروسي للتوسل الى سلام دائم
موسكو قالت في بيان للكريم لانها منفتحه
على الحوار الجاد الشريطه
تمثل بالحقائق الجديده على الارض في اشاره
الى ما حققته روسيا الى حد الان من خلال
ضم اربع مناطق اوكرانيه
الامين العام لحلف الشمال الاطلسي حذر
اوكرانيا والدول الغربيه من مغبه
الاستهانه بالرئيس الروسي
كبدت الجيش الروسي خسائر فريحه لكن في
الوقت ذاته نشاهد ان روسيا تجنن المزيد من
القوات وقد اظهر قدره كبيره على تحمل
الخسائر والمعاناه لا شيء يدل على ان
الرئيس بوتين غير خطته واهدافه في
اوكرانيا من الخطر الاستهانه بروسيا
عن وقف كامل لاطلاق النار في اوكرانيا منذ
انطلاق عمليتها العسكريه